to get a flight out of town at a time
certain with you know getting everybody
to come in from across the state you
need to fly privately
i need to fly private i can't fly with
the peasants
the peasants smell and have chickens
and now in order to fight the supposed
republican
jim crow assault this means that
democrats have every ability to
undermine the actual functioning
workings of democracy it's really
impressive do you see the
the unbelievable gaslighting and flip
here so the idea here is that
republicans are subverting elections by
saying that voters
should have verifiable means of voting
that is subverting elections that is the
new jim crow
meanwhile texas texas democrats in order
to stymie republicans
from pursuing this new jim crow get to
simply abscond from the state of texas
violate the law and shut down basic
majoritarian democracy
in texas okay unlike on the national
level where we have a 50-50 split
in the senate there is no 50-50 split in
texas republicans have an overwhelming
majority
in the state assembly in texas and so
democrats came up with a strategy they
didn't want to pass this voter id law
they didn't want to pass a couple of
bills that suggested that boys should
play with boys and girls with girls
in sports and so they got on a plane and
they flew to washington dc
in order to deny republicans a quorum
and these are the heroes of the day
according to the media
if you undermine democracy by simply
walking out of the chamber and leaving
the state
so that you can't be brought back to the
chamber to vote in majoritarian fashion
now you're a hero you see the filibuster
is bad a long-held
standard in the united states senate
that's supposed to promote debate
and and conciliation that's really bad
and anti-democratic but
if an entire political party in texas
picks up that's on a private jet and
flies to washington dc while patting
themselves on the back
in order to deny the workings of
democracy that's not only not
anti-democratic it is pro-democratic you
see
now you may be saying yourself i don't
see a consistent standard here correct
you don't there is none
there is no consistent standard when it
comes to the democratic party and the
media the answer is whatever forwards
the agenda is good and whatever does not
for the agenda is jim crow
and joe biden is fully on board with
this because the way you hold political
power according to joe biden
is you gin up an enormous amount of faux
outrage and then you claim that your
political opponents
are the equivalent of george wallace
standing in a schoolhouse door
okay so texas democrats have sconded
over the course of the last couple of
days
they just picked up and they got a
private jet and they left and they
partied it up
in fact uh they were they were bragging
about what a wonderful time they were
having in washington dc these are true
emissaries of the people by the way they
got in a private jet
and they brought along a case of miller
light just in case any of them decided
that
their drinking habit couldn't last for
the four hour flight from
texas from austin to washington dc gene
wu a texas legislator tweeted out
a a picture of what appears to be a
caesar salad with croutons
he said my fist meal as a fugitive i
assume he meant a first
meal i don't wanna know what he does in
in the privacy of his own home so my
fist meal is a fugitive
delicious what a hero and then he
tweeted out again
landed safely in dc officially out of
arrested jurisdiction of governor abbott
it was wonderfully to random it was
wonderfully to randomly run into people
who recognize me and applauded what we
are doing yes i'm sure that that was
happening a lot i'm sure that people
were just randomly running into this
anonymous state legislator and they were
like that guy's a hero and then
you have a hero shot a bunch of texas
state legislators
are standing very solemnly but happily
in front of the united states capital
because nothing says
appealing to texas voters quite like
absconding to washington dc
and asking the federal government to
step in and quash the workings of the
texas state legislature
really really solid texas legislative
stuff one of the congress people tweeted
out it takes a village
on the bus from dulles to dc last night
doing the lawrence o'donnell show oh the
heroism oh
she was doing the lawrence o'donnell
show from her cell phone my god it's
like normandy
julie johnson of texas held the camera
light see ordaz perez plugged in my
phone to her computer as it was dying
ramos for texas found the bus outlet
hashtag women helping women yes
it's just like malala yousafzai trying
to stump for
afghan women not being crammed into
basements and and clubbed and
acided in the face for for the crime of
going to school these that's women
helping women women helping women
is making sure that the camera is steady
while you do a hit on lawrence o'donnell
from your plush chartered bus to
washington dc
oh the heroism they're stopping jim crow
guys so much stopping
of the jim crow okay so some of these
texas democrats have been asked about
their obvious
hypocrisy and the ridiculousness of of
flying first class private jet
no masks to dc to appeal for the federal
government's help
and uh one texas democrat says you know
we need to fly private we're just it's
like john kerry
i i need to fly private i can't
i'm important i can't fly with the
peasants
the peasants smell and have chickens
there is a texas democrat explaining why
they need they must fly private
when you break a quorum you want to be
successful so i think everybody wants to
see
you know 51 52 55 democrats on the same
plane that's reassuring number two
uh you know to to get a flight out of
town uh at a time certain with
you know getting everybody to come in
from across the state you need to fly
privately
and as you can see from the picture
we're talking about using the same kind
of
plane that the public uses every day
there's no there's no fancy couches or
anything like that this was just a
regular plane that moved us from one
state to another
well you know they needed to because
they needed the reassuring picture of
all the texas democratic legislators
fleeing the state it the the sort of
self-congratulatory nature of this that
that's just the beginning
texas democrats then in one of the most
cringe-worthy political videos
of the last couple of years they gather
together to sing we shall overcome
you know like the civil rights anthem we
shall overcome because it turns out that
stumping against voter id and making
sure that biological boys can play
against girls
and then absconding from the state in
order to ensure that requires you
to sing civil rights marching songs as
though you are martin luther king and
selma
these people are a joke we will overcome
we will overcome we will
it's my kid's talent show right there
that is that is not that is not good
stuff
number one somebody get somebody who can
sing number two
you know i'm noticing usually when
people do civil rights marches and they
sing things like we shall overcome i'm
noticing an awful lot of uh lack
of anyone giving a crap i see the
difference between selma and that is you
know the dogs the hoses
the armed police here it's just a bunch
of texas democrats standing there and
their arm has stretched three inches
from their from their inability to pat
themselves on the back properly
without an actual physical arm
stretching who's got two thumbs and
wants you
to like and subscribe